joining us now is Broward County Public
Schools Superintendent his name is
Robert Runcie Thank You mr. Runcie for
joining us I know this is a painful and
difficult day for you yesterday you said
no parent should ever have to send their
kids to school and not have them
returned what are the questions you are
asking this morning
I'm sorry what was the what questions
where is in his work yes what is the
question you are asking this morning
your Parkland community was voted one of
the safest in Florida what are the
questions you are asking this morning
well we we certainly continue to work
with law enforcement as this is a
continuing active crime scene at the
school our focus today and going forward
each and every day is on our students
our families our staff to provide
counseling and support today we have
opened four locations two in the
Parkland community two in Coral Springs
to provide grief counselors to help our
families on our students and staff as we
deal with this horrific situation and
has come to to our community Victor Cruz
this Victor Cruz has been described as a
very troubled student very violent have
you been Nicolas Cruz have you been able
to determine how he was able to get back
on that campus yes my understanding and
the information I have from law
enforcement is that he arrived on a
campus possibly through an uber driver
had dropped him off he arrived around
the time of dismissal entered the
building began to fire into the building
smoke from the firearm also set off the
fire alarm
he proceeded through the two floors of
the building
and and also at the end discarded his
firearm and gear that he had on and
exited the building along with students
who were evacuating he was apprehended
NIT about a mile or so from the school I
think law enforcement did a tremendous
job that response has been outstanding
and we continue to work with them as we
investigate this thing yesterday we
obviously continue to focus on our
students and families as a highest
priority we provided counseling to them
we transition students back with their
families and law enforcement also
interviewed students and faculty to
gather information regarding this this
tragedy well please know our condolences
are with you and your community our
hearts are heavy too given what has
happened thank you Robert Runcie for
joining us